El fantasma de un supuesto golpe de
estado sigue rondando en Brasil el
testimonio del senador Marcos Duval
cercano al expresidente Jair bolsonaro
donde delata una presunta conspiración
para evitar que Lula asumiera reflotó la
controversia sobre las presiones que
bolsonaro habría llevado a cabo para no
dejar el poder Duval relató como el
diputado Daniel silveira lo convocó a
una reunión secreta con bolsonaro el 9
de diciembre para proponerle un plan
desestabilizador
la idea era que colocaran el equipo de
grabación habría un vehículo cerca del
tribunal supremo grabando el audio y yo
en esta reunión con el ministro
Alexandre lo llevaría a decir que en
algunos de los procesos traspasó la
línea de la Constitución y de inmediato
dije que no haría eso no haría ese tipo
de cosas y le dije mire presidente y
Daniel esto es ilegal para hacer esta
grabación Ustedes deben tener
autorización del juez
mientras que este jueves Lula en una
entrevista con red de TV volvió a
apuntar contra su predecesor por
aquellos acontecimientos
este ciudadano preparó el golpe querían
hacer ese lío el primero de enero pero
se dieron cuenta que no era posible
porque había mucha seguridad y gente en
la calle estoy seguro de que bolsonaro
participó activamente en esto y Está
tratando de participar
en Orlando bolsonaro se dirige a un
grupo de Seguidores se pasó miércoles y
lamentó los hechos del 8 de enero
causados por personas a quienes calificó
como insignificantes el expresidente que
aún no reconoció la victoria Lula en las
elecciones está en Estados Unidos
tramitando una visa de seis meses y
admitió que le gustaría continuar allí
por un tiempo